Thomas hater is one of Germany's most
loved astronauts the first to go on a
spacewalk he spent a year conducting
research in space and is now a leading
advisor at the European Space Agency and
joins us here on made in Germany what's
it like up there it's fantastic the view
of our own planet and in the opposite
direction to the depth of space it's
just faced the fascinating I'm a very
jealous man but tell me what has and
have all those experiences that you've
made up there what has all that actually
brought us besides the odd gadget or two
okay there are of course a lot of
advances in science in the area of
medicine better understanding of how
bones behave osteoporosis is one of the
most distributed diseases so
contributions their disease of the
immune system new ways to discover
starting heart diseases new materials we
developed based on the research at their
new kind of material which can be used
for turbine blades reducing
significantly the weight of jet engines
and thus reducing the fuel consumptions
I can go on for a long time so a lot of
benefits but but are we talking about
earning profits when we come to the pure
business aspect of space explorer
exploration is an extremely expensive
journey well I would not agree that it's
extremely expensive Europe spends about
three and a half billion euros per year
the European Space Agency plus the
income from the European Union is about
5.2 billion euros if you compare it to
the annual budget for space in the
United States which is around 18 19
billion dollars I think it's okay and
yes it's worth the effort in terms of
the knowledge we gain and the
fascination that is also caused by young
generation what are Europe's chances
though of increasing that budget to what
a proposed 11 billion it's a little bit
less for the next three years yes about
seven and a half eight billion for the
running probe
and for starting new programs space has
become part of our day to day life much
more than many people might be aware of
so I think it's an excellent investment
and you can't compare Europe to the u.s.
there what do you think of the most
famous space entrepreneur right now Iran
maskim and his ambitions to colonize
Mars first of all I think Ellen mask did
a remarkable job in designing this new
launcher not only talking about it but
he did it he said he will recover the
first stages and he did it now on his
vision to mass I think it's very
interesting to bring humans to our
neighboring planet mid of the next
decade I have to admit I'm a little bit
curious if this is feasible towards
right a pleasure to have an astronaut on
the show thank you very much